anti-feminist attorney which is
anti-family he's an attorney yeah
apparently so
i guess he fights for men's rights which
is a weird classification i didn't know
you had to fight for men's rights
wait i read that the guy killed himself
after he did
allegedly that's what they say right
right right but who really knows
yeah when when they took me out to go
shoot guns i shot this i don't know the
i don't know gun names
but it's the one that looks like a
cowboy gun but it's big bullets
what's up everybody welcome to another
episode of the genius brain podcast we
got the elite crew
once again we got our man pat here
sexy man pat [ __ ] weddle
and then we got nick the big ass ear
dude
my man could hear your feelings with
those things it's hard
what's that what's that what's up what's
that i saw an old picture of me as a
little kid dog
it like no joke this is the shape of my
head my ears came up to be this big
yeah you ever look at like old pictures
of yourself with the kid and you go it
makes sense why i got bullied
no for sure for sure that's like my
picks too i'm like
i would have taken my own lunch money
yeah yeah i was like no wonder everyone
called me dumbo and chased me around the
school and flicked my ears and [ __ ]
you kind of like my uh my cousin so my
cousin has when he was younger he used
to have big [ __ ] ears but he had
adult sized ears he just kind of he
literally grew into them
damn so his ears have been the same size
since he was a little kid he's actually
my manager now shout out to abe
oh shout out to him shout out shut up
shut up his ears used to be really
[ __ ] big and i used to always make
fun of his [ __ ] ears
but then he had a fat [ __ ] head now
so it matches
fat ass head and fat ass ears how does
that work do you your ears so your ears
come out the size that they are
and then you your head grows all i know
is that or do they grow until they get
to the day you die your nose and your
ears keep growing that's why you see old
people look like gremlins
yeah they got giant they got droopy ones
yeah and they're like little meadows
growing their [ __ ] hair
little little [ __ ] bunnies are like
hopping in there and [ __ ] because like
in asian
in asian culture what your your ears
being bigger is like your earlobes it
means like prosperity everything in
asian culture is like oh
if you have long hair or big ears you're
always going to be rich like that's what
they always want
really long hair about no i don't know i
just made that up usually it's like ears
or something
don't just lead the viewers like holy
[ __ ] i cut my hair
every day i'm sure there's something
about like long hair i don't know man
i know big ears is a big thing biggers
is the one i know for sure because my
mom used to always tell me that but it's
not really happening
baby you're the most annoying
unsuccessful person i've ever met
i'm fine okay i [ __ ] hate you so much
my sister sold it it was her car that i
was driving oh that's right your boy's
whipping the miata baby
my dream carlo 2003 prius my guy
ah damn that [ __ ] miata is a piece of
[ __ ]
it is let me tell you earlier that miata
has glycoma
it's so fun to drive though like now i'm
driving man i miss this in what way
it's just like you know how to drive
stick let me tell you something right
okay here comes a stick conversation
right i haven't drove a stick in ages
driving stick is fun driving stick is
stupid here's the reason why you're
right
that's like watching transmissions for a
[ __ ] reason that's like me watching
all my movies on vcr it's like hey dude
get a dvd player
that's the most obnoxious thing that i
think like car heads do and they go oh
you don't know how to drive stick it's
like no i also want [ __ ] watch vhs as
either dumb [ __ ]
like why the hell would i what why you
don't like to rewind your movies i think
i think i think it's really cool when
they do that it is cool but it's
it becomes immediately uncool when the
guy's like yeah dude you just [ __ ]
won with the road
see i'm not saying [ __ ] yourself it's
what i'm saying is
now i'm having a lot of fun driving it
in a week i'm going to be like [ __ ] this
car
because i sometimes when driving stick
is a pain in the ass if i farted in your
car it would explode
that's how ridiculously small that car
is i got a smog check today if you're an
adult you should not drive a miata no i
got a smog check today and the guy was
pretty much kind of like [ __ ] talking to
me about like
how small the car is he's like yeah i
got in the car and you know i couldn't
put my knees to the steering wheel the
whole time my knees are crunching up to
my chest and i'm like yeah i get it okay
dude the car is small
it's like what do you want me to do all
right my business is also closing
tomorrow it's like i
probably know why man you're an [ __ ]
nobody likes
you dude you're being a jerk talking
[ __ ] you know what new car's coming out
though
a car that hasn't been made in like 20
30 years uh the ford broncos
oh yeah i heard about dope as [ __ ] and i
got a stupid forerunner
this year she didn't wait it out for the
bronco but my [ __ ] honda element rest
in peace baby i love you so much
she got a white ford get that kill with
the hamsters dude get the hamster car
baby or they're dancing
i actually would have gotten that car if
i could fit in it but i couldn't yeah
you're too big for those cars
i would i would love to see you try to
get into my car and see how long it
would take you to get in and get out
let's drive after this let's go for a
little let's go i'll give you right here
i don't think so it'll be like a skate
you put it on like a [ __ ] roller
skate just pedal the other
start lacing it to my foot you're
[ __ ] ridiculous yeah that car is so
small was that your old miata the one
you had before yeah where was it the
whole time
it was just parked on my mom's damn yeah
yeah and your sister sold your car
well that was her car i was driving her
car she let you know that she sold it or
just one day
i was like sell the car oh okay that one
dude some dude
i just come back and my car is gone why
don't you just buy that 2003 prius
you know what i should i should why
wouldn't you just buy that 2003
prius i want to but it's like you know
level up son yes
i just like it is the preferred choice
of the lgbt community it is
it is so is the miata so no they they
actually have standards
all right they are good people don't you
dare talk about these people
that have pulled over to the side to ask
me to buy the miata from me
right then and there who
it was a year ago i might as well just
be on this podcast and be like dude i
had so much [ __ ]
why did you have this dick when did
these people come up
this happy the south pass south pasadena
you're a neck of the woods
david so and this thanks for telling
everybody where i live yeah this man
lives
dm me for his address if you guys need
his address
go ahead please continue the story i
want to hear this story
this this handsome older man pulled up
next to me in a rav4
you know he's salt and pepper hair and
he was like hey i would like to buy the
miata from you
are you selling this car or would you be
interested in selling this and i was
like sorry man this is a collector's
edition i'm not going to be selling this
and he was like all right go [ __ ]
yourself then and drove right off wow
wow yeah so that happened one time
how many times
so many times probably like seven or
eight times
that's happened but other than that and
he wasn't joking he was serious
he wanted to buy the car for me and i
was like sorry man not for sale and then
how much would you sell that piece of
[ __ ] for i don't know people really like
the miata though
people like it for some reason but the
insides of the miata
are running it's a two-seater right yeah
there's there's no space for anything
else
how can you drive that you're you're a
coach you're a trainer what what can you
fit in that thing
explain that to me my bag my gym bag my
barbell brigade
gym bag there's no room for your dignity
though
that's been long gone absolutely [ __ ]
nuts that's been long
well i know this guy's gonna be [ __ ]
hyped because he's been talking about
the epstein [ __ ] the whole time
so hyped about [ __ ] kid diddlers i'm
not hyped okay hold on dude i just like
when they're
brought to justice
broad shoulders and they're and they're
naturally handsome
nah man it's uh it's how can he not be
interested in this story bro that [ __ ]
is crazy the judge
thing so this judge was appointed to his
case right
yeah and then they accepted that i bet
people turned it down though i bet other
judges were like i ain't touching that
[ __ ] dude i had no idea how easy it was
to kill somebody
all you have to do is dress up as a
fedex person and then you just
[Music]
did you want to actually did you hit
they found the guy
that that killed the son of the judge
and attempted to kill the husband and
apparently he's like a
they call him like a a trump supporter
slash
anti-feminist attorney which is
anti-feminist he's an attorney
yeah apparently so i guess he fights for
men's rights which is
a weird classification i didn't know you
had to fight for midfield
wait i read that the guy killed himself
after he did up
allegedly that's what they say right
right right but who really knows
but the thing about that is it's like i
think they're trying to spin it as
this guy is just like a crazy trump guy
oh for sure and that's what they're
that's what the narrative probably is
but i feel like it's too far gone
everyone's like yeah right dude
what are the odds that this epstein [ __ ]
this guy this random trump supporter
dresses up like a fedex driver all
of a sudden goes to this judge's house
two days after she's been appointed to
handle this case so
and then knocks the door like hey guys
and then just starts dumping and the
dips out
there what they're trying to say is that
he has a vendetta against that judge for
earlier i think another case that
happened between them [ __ ] that's
what they're saying but
who knows who knows if that's true and
also apparently
jeffrey epstein's private banker was
found dead
hanging that was like in 2019 right no i
heard this was recent
why are people not do people just take
this information just go
somebody died and they just walk about
their day this is some
like double 07 movie type of [ __ ] it's
movie [ __ ] yeah it's straight movie [ __ ]
brief [ __ ] pelican you ever seen that
movie no julia roberts
look it up what is this movie i don't
know i forgot it's like
i think the shittiest name ever pelican
brief yeah yeah it's about like
i don't know actually i don't know what
it's about the endangered pelican yeah
yeah i would imagine it's about like you
know yeah this type of stuff
yeah this guy right here
i want to see him on a cnn debate dude
it's like a pelican what does the
pelican bring right let me take some
guys
[ __ ] yeah so
okay so what's your what's your theory
what's gonna happen i don't know what's
gonna happen tell me what you think is
gonna happen break it down right now i
feel like
everyone's gonna get away with it the
son died immediately because he got shot
in the chest right he just opened the
door and just went bow mm-hmm
just started like dumping on everybody
just pop up because the dad got hit too
but he survived or something
damn you could just be opening up doors
like that huh well if you see a fedex
guy you're like what the [ __ ] is the
fedex guy that's
the last fetish that knocked on my door
i shot him
i shot him first yeah yeah he goes is mr
so here
nice try i probably shouldn't say that
on the air you're probably gonna get
arrested for that
for what killing a man
[Laughter]
i get nervous when people come to my
door though even if it's a ups
or fedex dude just because i've heard a
lot of these random stories of people
you know dressing up as fake guys to
raid homes and stuff
because house rates are actually pretty
big in sacramento um even in
my neighborhood about a couple of years
ago
um a bunch of people were just raiding
homes in the area and they weren't
it wasn't anything particular too they
just did it in the most brutal way
possible they would kick the [ __ ]
door down
tie up the family grab the [ __ ] and run
damn damn yeah and even in um
where me and joe live there was a dude
that we know um
actually i don't really know him that's
joe's friend but he put me into a group
chat
but his house got robbed uh not too long
ago and this is during when
the the whole code should just be really
enough yeah i think neighborhood watch
yes chat that we're in yeah the
neighborhood watch the one that joe got
his he got his house robbed
so not joe but one of the guys in there
right so he got he's my client
oh is he yeah well he got if we're
talking about the same person
the asian guy right yeah yeah yeah so he
got robbed him and his wife got tied up
to a chair
what the [ __ ] are you serious and they
beat the [ __ ] living [ __ ] out of him
hilarious
and so this time
i should hit him i haven't hit him up in
a while do you think he's asking you to
train him because he's going to say what
it is i was training him pre-coveted
yeah and so before this and you're
not nothing you taught him worked out in
that situation no we've been
weightlifting
we've been weightlifting so i guess we
got to start doing some boxing maybe
some boxing because he got this [ __ ]
beaten out of them tied up
and they they jacked the business dude
yeah they jacked a whole bunch of his
stuff
oh my god yeah in the day at night or in
the daytime i think this was during the
this is after work so they followed his
car into his house and they beat the
living [ __ ] out of him which makes me
believe that
that's actually somebody that he knows
no for sure that's somebody knows yeah
because if we're thinking about the same
person
they would have a reason to to rob him
yeah
so [ __ ] you know what i'm saying so this
like these home invasion stuff is
it's a little scary man that [ __ ]
happens yeah yeah i think that's why
i've seen them shooting guns
recently you got a gun well i want to
get one i've been thinking about getting
again can't believe you don't have a gun
dude you must not care about your lady
do you have a gun huh
don't worry about what i got
what do i need a [ __ ] gun for when i
have a spiked pick trap in front of my
house
god damn david has a moat around his
house
no but i i've been trying to get so i
when i was younger i had an illegal
firearm that somebody gave me
what kind of gun was it it was a clock
that's what i want to get
it scared the living [ __ ] [ __ ] out of
me because i didn't know how to use a
gun
he was just like hey he's like you're
gonna need this not psyched thanks blood
and i grabbed it and i was like oh geez
oh my god what do i do with this i
actually don't know what happened to the
gun
because i left it when i went to uh
riverside ucr where did you leave it
uh i left it in this hidden spot in so
in my house there's this back area we
call it the shed it's not a shed it's
like a
it's like a separate living space right
but it doesn't have a bathroom but it
has air conditioning and all that [ __ ]
uh i hid it behind my bed against the
wall
and i cut open uh one of the uh the the
hardwood floor slats and i put it under
there
damn wow i'm scared i want to get caught
you know but i went back and it was gone
so that means
that means my dad found it and he did
something with it yeah but he keeps it
on his because there's no way that gun
just [ __ ] disappears
it was hidden i asked your dad to lift
up a shirt next time
what's up like you talking [ __ ] yeah
it's a piece of [ __ ] is that lip out
here
[Laughter]
but definitely my dad either found that
gun or something else or
i didn't put that gun back in that
hiding spot well i don't know where the
[ __ ] it is
i i guarantee you don't know where it is
i bet i bet you misplaced it maybe but
it's not in there though
oh that's true i do lose a lot he loses
his phone every five minutes
so actually but i think you'd be
responsible but the gun is like
so heavy that like come on and also if
you did all that you [ __ ] engineered
the ground and like made a little
trap door because he probably because
the shed thing was something that
you know they kind of build it in the
backyard and has electricity and
everything else but if you just cut open
the the hardwood floor on the bottom
it's just concrete and like two by four
slats that kind of hold everything up
and so it was just super easy just to
pop it and put it down but
um yeah i don't know where it went so
so for all of you know someone somebody
somebody died with your gun
and he has your fingerprints on it so
for all the listeners at home this is
how you
uh properly hide an illegal firearm yes
and it was so weird getting that gun and
i talked about this on a podcast with
joe but i just remember having it you're
holding like a sandwich right and i was
just like
and i just got right no this is how you
hold the gun dude like this gun safety
i held this cut right and then when i
was putting mayonnaise on it i was like
this tastes funny
this is a very weird tasting firearm
so holding this gun right this is just
like cold cuts
there's a river i was like this is scary
and it and it scared the living [ __ ] out
of it just holding it right
just because at that time when i at that
age with the type of people that i knew
uh people die from the [ __ ] yeah and so
the only way i was able to dispel my
fear of it is when bart and joe took me
out to go shoot guns
yeah and i was like okay now i know how
to use this i know how to you know do
the
pop little cartridge thing out safety
thing don't put your finger on the
trigger
point it down to point that up kind of
thing right that see that's the thing
and like it sucks because it's on safety
right
in california like before a corona like
if you mentioned
uh owning guns people looked at you like
you believed in the devil they're like
what the [ __ ] do you like
but like part of the solution is that
gun safety gun training because i
remember like i grew up with guns my dad
owned guns when i was younger
and uh i was scared too i still get
nervous kind of when i hold them but i
was like eight at the time my dad was
like hold this
smart man he's like that's power son he
was like bang bang
you don't need an education you just
need a gun see that armor truck
go but uh
yeah dude i mean he taught me how to
like always make sure it's unloaded like
any assume any gun is loaded whatever by
pointing down all these things that you
talked about
um but that's that's crucial dude i feel
like a lot of people
uh would benefit from that there'd be
way less accidents you know
and uh i don't they're they're just
super demonized but when you go out and
you shoot
like it's always something that you need
to respect but it is [ __ ] super
intense dude like
yeah i i when when they took me out to
go shoot guns i shot this i don't know
the i don't know gun names
but it's the one that looks like a
cowboy gun but it's big bullets
[Laughter]
you know the yosemite samsung caveman
just driving
i don't know what kind of and even
you're like no it's a [ __ ] it's like
big
man i'm actually throwing up gang signs
you guys are going to die in a couple of
hours
was it a shotgun no it was not a shotgun
it was a handgun it's a thing that goes
click like yeah like a revolver revolver
it's the one that goes bang and it and
it's so
[ __ ] crazy powerful it clocks back
it's probably 357 right probably yeah
it's a 549 hyphen 7-7
yeah that's what it was baby elon musk's
kid's name
yeah that's it 5477-9
skew number 82. excuse me
because i shot it and it just went yeah
right yeah
that gun i never wanted to touch again
yeah it was it's crazy though just how
powerful that is that if i shot someone
they'd be dead
yeah you'd put a hole through your
[ __ ] wall it made me uh question a
lot of action films when somebody gets
shot seven times and they're like
i need you to shoot me one more yeah
i just went shooting recently probably
like six months ago
and i was when i got there i was super
amped i was like yeah we're gonna shoot
some guns and once i got to the
gun range i was like i got really scared
and like holding the gun
and then just like learning how to shoot
again it was super scary but once you
get in the rhythm of things you do feel
a lot more comfortable
yeah i think people are just afraid of
like kind of what they don't know it's
it's intense and it should be you should
give it a respect you should be able to
be
respectful with it because it is you
could easily [ __ ] somebody up or
yourself up
pre-coven tiffany was not about having a
gun in the house
she was like nah we ain't doing that i
got into a stupid argument with somebody
about
oh i actually know who this is you know
who you [ __ ] are he's a really good
friend of mine
but he's a little dumb and he's also
very extreme with his opinions
but uh after i shot the the firearm
right i shot the firearm and we had we
were
i went back to sacramento and we're
chilling at this old at this homie's
house
and then we were watching scarface right
and you guys remember the last scene in
scarface
where he gets you know and he starts
shooting [ __ ] up
wait describe it okay so he's in the
suit or some of some sort but he's in
his house
and people come in to shoot him why are
they trying to shoot him because he
stole candy from the
from the local liquor store oh okay and
they were really upset because there was
only two twizzlers
and he took three somehow math and so he
comes up right
and he gets shot up and as he's shooting
people up he's like
whatever i don't know what his line is
what is his famous line when he does
that [ __ ] say hello to my little friend
there it is say hello to my
little friend and he starts shooting it
and as he's shooting his firearm
he's getting shot at multiple times and
i said but is he still shooting
afterwards
he got shot yeah yes and he's
continually shooting and what i said to
him and i was like dude after i shot a
gun like for real for real
that shit's so fake he goes he looks at
me straight in my [ __ ] face and he
goes
nah you're being dumb and i looked at
him and i go
what do you mean i was like if you get
shot
30 times you're pretty much dead yeah
right i was like this film this part
right here is very fictitious he goes
nah dude adrenaline i'm sorry what
i'm sorry what 30 bullets to the body i
don't give a [ __ ] how much adrenaline
you have in your body you're
dead yeah but he was dead serious he
goes he goes if i was
amped up on coke and somebody shot me
with automatic weapons he goes i still
be able to stand up and fire back and
cap everybody
nah dawg this is a serious conversation
did you fight your homie for saying some
[ __ ] like that no
because a crazy person like that would
stab it
i kind of love people like that though
because it's like the lack of humility
and self-awareness because it's like
it's one thing that
like say you said that and in my mind if
i thought hmm what if i was all
coked out and had some adrenaline i
would my way to approach it would be
uh but hey man like but what if like i
was amped up on coke and adrenaline and
you'd be like i don't think so
but to be like nah dude you're a [ __ ]
idiot
like like i really don't know but i'm
gonna be like nah dude you're a [ __ ]
dumbass god
i wish i was not sure about anything
yeah right bro
the aggression in this man was unreal
see that's [ __ ] because
so like we're in a couple instagram
chats right and
like there's a couple of random people
that you know sometimes they'll send you
links
and but hey they'll send you a post and
you have to follow the post to
follow the page to look at the post and
there's one that
people always send me it's called uh the
site this instagram page called hood
site
i don't have you ever heard of it but
they show really [ __ ] graphic [ __ ] on
there and i don't know why i still
follow it
but sometimes they post stuff and
they'll show people getting shot
in like a liquor store in like queens or
something and you look at how
somebody when they get shot and the way
their body drops and the way they
their body reacts to it you're like that
doesn't happen in the [ __ ] movies
like because the way these bodies go
stiff when they get like shot in the arm
or the leg
yeah is the scariest [ __ ] thing it's
just like a sack of potatoes
and then they're like stiff and they're
just oh bro it's like
you can't recreate that in the movie so
i feel like people don't really
understand like what happens to
someone's
reality yeah like because it's so it's
so drastic it's so different than
what you see in the movie because now
when i go back and i watch the the rocky
films right and i see how many times he
gets punched in the face and he's just
alive
yeah right dead yeah it's unreal to me
right the ref would have stopped that a
long time when he fought
when he fights the russian guy i think
he lands like 47 left hooks
[Laughter]
and i'm still fine
baby okay i didn't drop that movie
though
rocky one one of the best films ever
dude [ __ ] one is amazing
it just got a little weird because as
the film continued to progress
he just became more and more stupid
because then all the meetings
hello continue the conversation that is
the uh the cleaning lady oh okay
continue she's very nice bro rocky she's
very nice
she's very nice to you guys [ __ ] david
right or what rocky one is sick but
honestly i know that they get stupid as
[ __ ] but
rocky honestly i think rocky iv is so
dope i think that's my favorite
america communism thing yeah and then
when he comes at the end of it he's like
if i can love gonna you guys then we can
[ __ ] do this together
he has that moment of bringing the world
rocky is this rockwork
is this the no the the the five is the
one with the the kid right that's the
one where he gets in a street fight and
he he's like mentoring the younger
fighters
i've never seen
[Music]
he's like
i loved how absorbently rich he was that
he had a robot in his house
yeah right yeah yeah especially back in
what like from like the
jetsons too it was like the robot from
the gym [ __ ] robot in this house and
his uh his brother-in-law just
wasted all of his [ __ ] money away so
sad yeah because that supposed to be
what that's
been like the 70s like the 80s 80s
imagine
having a fully functioning robot in the
[ __ ] 80s how expensive that would be
yeah you know paulie was so [ __ ] hard
to like in that probably suck
all the time he just was something he
was so useless he was super abusive to
uh
sister what was his sister's name uh his
wife i don't remember anything
about sylvester adrian there you go he
was so [ __ ] mean to her
i remember she made um she made the
turkey for thanksgiving and then he just
chucked it outside
yeah i was so upset
respect respect way to make your point
dude
that guy's a tough guy there was a scene
i remember when i watched it
again recently because it was on netflix
uh they put all the rockies up there
this was like a few years back
but there was a scene in the first one
where mick
came to rocky to ask him if he could
train him because he saw a lot of
promise him
but then he was he would it wasn't that
he was talking [ __ ] to rocky he just
didn't like the fact that he was
what he said a bum
he was a lone shark right and so when he
saw whatever the promise that he had in
him or whatever
mick comes up to him and he has a
conversation with the apartment and he's
basically
asking him mick to take him with him on
this ride because he doesn't have much
time left
and so he wants to experience glory
again through rocky by helping and
trained to become a really great boxer
but there was this very emotional moment
where rocky is just
pissed at him because like you didn't
give me a chance he goes what about me
but that moment right there i remember i
[ __ ] started tearing up bro i was
like
what about me you described you
described that better than the movie did
thank you that was that was amazing i
felt like i was watching and then that
was nice
then mick just starts he looks so
defeated he walks outside and there's a
scene where
you see mick just kind of going off in
the distance and then rocky comes
downstairs and he starts running towards
him he puts his arms over him i think
his arm's over him and they just start
walking and talking
and that's when he became his trainer
boom that's so dope it was one of the
most beautiful [ __ ] moments of
people his acting was so good i thought
sylvester stallone actually spoke like
that
like really like the whole time because
we were super young when we were
watching it yeah yeah and then
so when i thought he was doing other
roles that he was fixing up his accent
just to speak like what the [ __ ] is this
why is he doing that why is sliced alone
doing that we're supposed to be family
you know you do it
yeah you can't do his impression without
making that face i know
it's like a robber or like a robert de
niro style face you know i know like
really squinched it well one movie i saw
recently was um
a bronx tale you guys seen that movie i
don't remember it i saw one
bronze tale or bronx tale what did i say
i don't know what you said i said bronx
tale okay i don't know what this is
you've never seen the
gangster movie it's like a robert de
niro he directed it
oh you guys rubber chas palmettary jazz
pumpkin chess palmetto yeah he's he's
he's in every mafia movie he's always a
gangster in every mafia movie
he's never seen a bronx tale i've never
seen him all right guys
um podcast is over now explain it just
like the way i explained the scene
between
mick and rocky balboa um
it's about this young boy who lives in
the bronx boom
and his dad is a bus driver
he takes him around
his dad is a bus driver who was played
by
robert de niro okay but then their house
is right in front of a mobster bar
and the all the mobsters hang out over
there and it's just a battle
for this the father of this young boy to
pull him away from that mobster life
because he's kind of gets slowly pulled
in
over there and he wants him to be more
of a working man rather than
a mobster so that's that's pretty much
the movie it's a very good um
coming of age tale in uh the bronx i was
like wow
i just don't care yeah i'll never watch
that maybe not i know
i was going to watch the movie before
you start talking about it and now i'm
like nah i'll never watch it
so if you guys want me to break down any
other films like the pelican brief
i will you should reenact your favorite
scene from that movie right now
oh that would be fantastic just not but
only by yourself
okay so um there's a there's a very
pivotal scene where the young boy is
sitting out on the stoop
right and he's sitting on the stoop and
then a car pulls up
right and then another car pulls up and
these guys get out the car and they
start fighting
and one of the guys pulls out a baseball
bat and he starts smashing the
windshield
on one of the cars and everyone's like
what the
the young boy is looking around like
very scared
very worried about what's gonna happen
he's never seen an altercation like that
happen
right so the guy's smashing the
windshield and then
the big mobster sunny
sunny of course he walks out pistol 357
shoots the guy twice and then he walks
up on him shoots in the head bang right
in front of the kid damn
right cold blooded the kid is like what
the [ __ ] and everyone pulls the car out
all these mobsters come out and they all
take the cars and drive them away and
they just leave the dead body there
right and then sure enough the cops show
up
and they're they're they want to know
what happened there's no witnesses
right so they find out this little boy
saw the whole thing
right cops come up to the house
bobby de niro is with him his son they
walk him downstairs
and they see all the mobsters lined up
and they're all facing the wall right
so then you know what the cop wants
guess what he wants sex
that's afterwards okay that's some
epstein [ __ ] right there dude
sex in front of you i light these guys
up to watch you [ __ ]
that's what it is that's all it is it's
all these monsters he tells the mobsters
to turn around and there's a lineup
there's like eight of them
so he he takes the young boy the cop
takes the young boy and he says
i want you to show me who shot penis the
guy
no no that's that's a whole different
other one we're talking about epstein
right now yeah
my bad my bad i confuse you for a sec so
he he goes down the line of all the
mobsters and he's like hey
did this guy do it he says no no no no
no he goes up to sonny who's the head
honcho
the main man and they asked him hey did
this guy do it
and there's a long pause because you
don't know if this kid is going to
snitch on on
on young sunny right so they're looking
at each other there's a lot of shots of
just
their face and they all look worried
right and he goes nope
it wasn't him damn he didn't snitch and
the kid becomes a part of the gang
exactly boom and that's how it starts he
builds his close relationship with this
that's kind of like the the other bob
movie that's very famous not the good
it's the good fellas good fellas good
fellas right it was like he was a kid
and yeah he slowly became integrated to
the mob because of his you know
chutzpah you know but the the the um
i don't i don't i don't know i don't
think that's italian i don't even know
what that is
i don't know
or something like that i have no idea
i'm not very cultured outside of asia
stuff
i know nothing i i know absolutely
nothing i never said i did
dude you were explaining that scene
though i felt like i was like right
there dude
you know it's honestly a really good
movie yeah i would have snitched
immediately
because it was him i wouldn't know
what's going on i wouldn't know what's
going on
because he was always watching the
mobsters and they always he'd always
imitate them
i wasn't perceptive as a kid though and
he's like seven years old in this
[ __ ] movie you know
this podcast is brought to you by thrive
market have you ever woke up hungry and
like a stupid fool
looked into your fridge and realized it
was empty just like your spirit and
stomach you know what that means
you have to get up and go to the grocery
store which now more than ever is a
hassle and a pain in the ass
i hate going there especially driving
there and really why go through all that
when you have thrive
market when you shop online with thrive
the groceries and all other products you
need are there
organized and ready to be ordered at a
click of a freaking button
even something specific like if you're
on keto or payload you can shop for that
specific category as well it makes it
super easy on top of this as a member
you save 25 to 50 percent off
traditional retail prices
and their carbon neutral shipping is
free on orders over forty nine dollars
so listen up
i'm a proud thrive market member you
will be too try it risk free go to
thrivemarket.com
geniusbrain join today and you'll get up
to twenty dollars
in shopping credit towards your first
order that's t
h r i v e market dot com
slash geniusbrain to start your
risk-free membership
and get up to twenty dollars towards
your first order
that's thrive market dot com slash
genius brain you know what's interesting
is that that [ __ ] actually like that
life was kind of like what the mobster
dudes my dad grew up in chicago he said
he knew
like was in a neighborhood like that and
it was true like no one said [ __ ] to the
cops it was just very like
you didn't say [ __ ] it was just you
didn't see nothing you didn't know
nothing mobs just kind of took care of
the community obviously they were
criminals too and would [ __ ] you up
they would control everything yeah they
would extort [ __ ] obviously it
wasn't like all great robin hood [ __ ]
but like kind of part of me is like
that's sick that like doubles
you're just kind of people might there
needs to be accountability obviously but
it's kind of nice that people just mind
their [ __ ]
i would have been so good at that [ __ ]
though i would have i would have denied
evidence so [ __ ] well it'll be
ridiculous like somebody would get shot
right in front of me a cop was standing
right
there he's like you see that i'm like
see what
and i walk right over the body what are
you talking about you step on the crime
scene
see that kid right there see that little
slanted [ __ ] that [ __ ] kid did it
he's a [ __ ] kid yeah see that little
[ __ ] noodle eater give me some
[ __ ] kid
i like him
oh [ __ ] there you go
give me some [ __ ]
don't witness nothing you know why
because his eyes are always closed hey
hey forget about it forget about it
right
what are you talking about huh i would
just never see anything
at all crime happens right did you see
that i slammed it
i can't see [ __ ] it's the blanket
[Laughter]
that kid's blind he's like i don't know
what the [ __ ] you're talking about
you're like damn right he's blind i know
that kid's never [ __ ] ratted on
nobody
excuse me sir i don't see nothing i was
like yeah you're damn straight yeah
there's a bowler here's a bowl of
noodles get the [ __ ] out of here but i
don't see the noodles this kid's [ __ ]
good
they're good it's [ __ ] amazing we
call that pasta in my neighborhood
oh that'd be such a dope movie it's
about this kid that becomes like the top
mobster yeah just because he was
literally blind and he didn't see
anything he didn't see [ __ ]
and now he runs the mob and he's
confused he doesn't understand
what's happening what is [ __ ] going
on yeah you keep playing thumb there
gobble [ __ ]
and he's asian he's asian he runs
italian mom but he's asian dude that's a
[ __ ]
oh that's that's funny that's that's
your name
you did the the korean la riot thing now
you go back to the 60s and talk about
the one blind korean kid that joined the
mobsters because
i don't see nothing i
i never see anything right okay and he
rises to the top bang bang bang
every single scene is just me staring
off into the distance and people dying
around me
yeah exactly i just don't know what's
going on i'm sitting on piles of body
oh this is seen a little warm why does
it sit so hot
i don't understand where am i dude hell
yeah
david kid is a [ __ ] genius that guy
that's what i'll be saying
i'm just a witness in the stands like
what did you see i keep telling you i
don't see nothing i see brock i see
my mom's in the back yeah [ __ ] love
this kid
oh that's the perfect film dude that's
great oh somebody [ __ ] backed that
film yeah dude
start a gofundme and they're gonna
they're gonna uh produce it gotta get
the funds and
gobble [ __ ] too good electric bug
electric bug
that's what it is i think i think we're
good at making films i think i think so
too
yeah that's a solid idea do you do you
think that if you were born in the 60s
like back in the day right that you
could join
like one of those mobs easy nah just
because of how much stuff that they were
getting away with and how much power
that they had that's true
because it was different i felt like
rules are different i'd probably say
they are for sure
um i think like if i grew up poor in one
of those neighborhoods
it would have been hard not to like get
into that life but i mean i feel like
well i don't know i don't know how i
would have been but like [ __ ] people
up like really badly i would have felt
i personally like at this moment would
have felt guilty about that but
i think i don't know bro i think you'd
be fine i think you could do probably
like running like some bookie [ __ ] like
some gambling stuff i could see myself
definitely doing that oh this the kid
with the
[ __ ] the little french hat you know
french hat with the tweed jacket just
running around
yeah they're doing errands for everybody
yeah i can see myself doing that
i don't think i forgot your mail mister
i didn't forget my mail no you forgot
your mail
he's like i got his wallet and you guys
run yeah yeah
done easy [ __ ] i'll be doing at the age
of 40 just doing the same [ __ ] as a
paperboy
hey mister you're 40. i'm 13. it's like
all right mister
just start passing him dude you know we
should talk about we should talk about
the [ __ ] wayfare conspiracy what's up
with that [ __ ] dude that came out of
nowhere
this is so weird so i guess this kind of
developed either on reddit or
4chan something right or i think it was
reddit though but
uh wayfair they were having certain
items on there with names of people
that were going on for an exorbitant
amount of price
price like cabinets like a metal cabinet
that you see it like a and it was like
stacey maxwell
yeah stacy maxwell fourteen thousand
dollars oh
yeah sorry 14.99 and so you know
obviously
conspiracy theorists they they kind of
go off in their own thing and so they
were looking up some of these names of
people
like i don't know somebody was like
named like samir or something like that
and it was a missing person oh
and they're like okay well this is a
little odd and they started looking up a
few other items
and they were connected to missing
people as well first and last name
whoa which is a little weird right and
so uh wafer obviously denied it saying
like
no this these are industrial grade like
fireproof whatever type of cabinets they
look regular but these are actually
priced appropriately and then some
people were questioning about uh like
pillows like pillows were priced at
uh nine thousand nine hundred ninety
nine dollars but they're like no that's
a mistake it should have been like what
ten bucks there was there was like books
like like um textbooks for like a
thousand dollars
or something or it was i don't know how
much it was but they were basically
saying it was due to like an algorithm
mess up or something like that and then
it wasn't really true
easy and so great excuse me but some
people were doing this but they were
taking it was like some kind of russian
website where they would take the
sku number and they would put it in and
then a name of uh
of like a child would pop up or a photo
of a child would pop up
and so they're like oh what the [ __ ] are
these sku numbers for these children
what they later on found out that that
was debunked because apparently on that
russian website you could just put in
like
gabagooki and then a kid's face would
pop up and sew his face yeah it could be
literally anything and somebody's face
would pop
okay and the [ __ ] funniest thing that
i read about this and the reason why i
didn't want to talk about this is
because
i wanted to see how this unfolds and
everything was debunked
but there was an item about a kid that
that was going around on twitter and
everything else about this person that
was missing saying you know this person
went missing in
whatever year and that person put up a
facebook video saying
i'm here what the [ __ ] no way they're
like who keeps saying that i'm missing
like so i guess they went missing for
like four days as a kid
okay but they were found again and so
there's like a few people that are kind
of pissed
right because they're looking them up
trying to find out where they [ __ ]
live but they were missing when they
were younger but they were found like
three or four days later
wow crazy and so so with all this
information do you think the wayfarer
stuff is
legit do you think it's true that they
were they might be involved with that
type of stuff or do you think
with all the evidence that's come out
afterwards because all i heard was the
initial stuff
and in my mind i was like it's probably
true like
i bet i bet they might be doing there
was there was something about tom hanks
and his instagram photos
yeah about when people were showing
evidence of all the stuff going on i was
like
this seems kind of like it like a like a
like a stretch but i don't know because
nowadays it's like
i'm sure this stuff happens and i i feel
like people
that would do something like this i bet
they think they're slick and they could
do [ __ ] like that but like oh yeah we're
gonna name these cabinets
a female's name and we're going to sell
it and we're going to use it to sell
[ __ ]
humans for trafficking you know like i
bet they would do some [ __ ] so
why would you want to buy children
they're so [ __ ] annoying yeah
but for what purpose like [ __ ] those
kids dude i hope they get
found yeah i hope they're safe but what
i mean is like
who wants kids like [ __ ] them dude yeah
unless they're your children that you
love
yeah [ __ ] random kids man no not [ __ ]
them though like that but
you know that's what's getting around
that is not what it is that is not what
i meant watch the whole video
watch the whole video where i was
talking about gaba gooks
but i think you're right like why but
that would mean that these people that
are trying to buy these kids
their only reason for buying them is to
traffic them
because why else that's so [ __ ] it's
so [ __ ]
it's so [ __ ] and it's like i hope it's
not true but then again
that's some good [ __ ] literally like
putting it right in front like remember
they're playing bingo and get out with
the dude
but like i mean what's up with the
missing names though that's kind of
weird right that they a bunch of the
cabinets were the names of people
but that's weird that's strange yeah i
guess with somebody uh there's a couple
of articles that i read they said that
if you literally look at ikea or
anything they have names of whatever
like
oh okay they just named [ __ ] what's the
name that you would get at ikea
what's the name of like a piece of
furniture dude the donker freak without
having
a doctor dude i love that piece of
furniture yeah there's
way too many consonants in this word
there's no way i can pronounce this
i need that shoe rack the there's a
focus in an opponent the j
and the k and the n there should be
vowels in between those two swedish
they have so many dots and different
like dots
like what the [ __ ] is this i feel like
they just they like they write a
sentence and then they're just like
spruce it up one of the funniest things
that happened i have
already uh named z he's swedish but he's
chinese he's chinese swedish
wow when we went to uh ikea out in
burbank
there was a swedish man at the door he's
obviously had a very thick swedish
accent doesn't speak much english
and z speaks fluent swedish
swadash
and he says you know hello to him in
swedish and then z responds back and he
just has like a full sentence on and the
guy literally looks at him and he goes
hello he doesn't want to speak swedish
to z at all and i'm like
he's [ __ ] swedish like speaks speak
swadash to him
but the man [ __ ] refused and he was
just trying to speak but it was so hard
because we were trying to ask him
um it was like a specific item that
we're gonna look for and we don't wanna
go search for anything so he wanted to
ask him where this stuff is at or where
he could find it on the floor plan
but he kept on trying to talk to him in
english and he's just getting so
frustrated he's like bro
your english sucks just saying in
swedish yeah yeah but he refused to do
it
which is so weird what the [ __ ] company
policy maybe huh you know that right
it's company policy
or he's gonna get put into a cabinet
yeah dude he's gonna be
turned into a cabinet trying to make him
one he's a trinidad lampshade
that's like that's like an episode of
stranger what was that scary-ass show uh
when i was a kid it was
what that guy would come out and he's
like factor oh fact or fiction do you
guys remember that show was a factor
vision factor fiction the guy that was
in star trek he would come out and it
was like don't
d he'd be like fact is stranger than
fiction and then was he always wearing
like a duster he was wearing like a
blazer and they would tell you like
six stories in a row and then at the end
of the show you had to like when you're
watching them you're like i don't know
if that's facts
and at the end they would tell you like
which ones are factored and which one
were fiction
there's somebody on youtube like that
his name is uh
matthew santoro i believe but he's like
this bald white guy
uh he used to do that [ __ ] his [ __ ]
channel pop the [ __ ] off he does have a
beard
yeah he has a beard he's like a redhead
i saw him talking i think it was him
but i saw him talking about like the
whitaker family have you heard about
that
what's that so we talked about that oh
yeah yeah the whitaker family is a bunch
of like um
it was five generations of inbreeding in
this place called tight it's [ __ ] up
it's odd west
west virginia yeah like we looked at it
on the map there it's 700 population 700
people live in this place
west virginia but it looks like nobody
can live there like there's literally
like seven houses
in this like i don't even know how big
the town is but it's it's so tiny
and they're i guess they're just a bunch
of inbred
i think it was a there's a uncle
nephew and then two other ladies i don't
know who it's [ __ ] up dude like have
you ever
seen true detective have you ever seen
the first season true tonight uh i saw
it yeah i saw half that seasoning
wait okay you only saw half that season
well because you kept
harping about it you [ __ ] loser dude
every time we came in every time we came
to the train everything true detective
when he gets on a show he will [ __ ]
harass you until you watch it
detective season one true detective
season one's pretty is amazing
it is and i'll fight you right here for
the next reason why i only watched half
of it
i work do you understand too i do too
this was this is how it starts it's the
first week
uh in in the whole week of training he
goes i just started watching the show
called true detective you should watch
it right
cut to end of week i just watched two
seasons
how did you know that's that's a lie
there wasn't a second season at the time
how did you work and watched two seasons
before the second season came out
it's only eight episodes right he got it
released
it was a chinese version and it was all
in chinese and he still watched it yeah
yeah that's exactly what happened but
what were you talking about the
whitaker's wait
the reason why i mentioned that is
because at the end of that season
remember when they see the serial killer
so they they go in his house and it's
just literally like
like chairs stacked on top of it's like
furniture stacked it's just a [ __ ]
mess dude there's like
twinkies and sandwiches laying around
it's just like trash house that's what
this whitaker family house looked like
it looked like just [ __ ] like couches
on top of couch
just like a like a landfill just like
like that [ __ ]
and uh just there was like four people
in the video and there were
like five generations of inbreeding one
dude just barked like he didn't talk
he didn't talk and he was like his name
was ray they'd be like this girl was
like hey ray come on the bus
and then he came out and he's like
and then i'd be like so are you feeling
good today literally yeah he's like
right
right right yeah and one of nick's
associates is down with incest
so i'll say this he's a dear friend of
mine i love this man to death
okay hold on a second this is the thing
and that's what that's
this dude he's one of my dearest friends
he's going to be one of my groomsmen i
love this dude to death but he likes to
go on this tangent where he just likes
to argue about [ __ ] just to argue like
he's just a contrarian
yeah like he just wants to like argue so
what he was saying was
inbreeding is bad let me drink my capri
sun yeah goes he goes he goes
and and you know him too so you
understand how he is but like he was
saying like
i don't understand why the government
always has to stick their nose in other
people's business
like for instance if people want if
people won't have sex with their
siblings they should be able to
silence
nothing no one is fighting for that at
all
i'm trying to figure it out bro who's
who's like protesting [ __ ] yeah he
very profound that was going to blow
your mind and then all he did was go
i'm distancing myself from you now i'm
walking we were all like do you want to
[ __ ] your brother bro
because you you can if you want no one's
gonna say anything
i'm not gonna snitch you out but i also
told him i was like if you had a sister
you would not be saying any of this [ __ ]
yeah you would not be saying this
because you want a bet
i had a sister i was [ __ ]
it was
yeah have you seen our son
he's a [ __ ] cocker spaniel bro and
like in the whitaker family like
all their eyes are like looking opposite
directions yeah it's [ __ ]
it's really [ __ ] bro it's super it's
sad when you watch it it's super sad
this is [ __ ] up and it's not like
funny because people [ __ ] with them like
that live in the town like they'll go
like and they'll [ __ ] with their house
they'll run out the driveway why would
they [ __ ] with their house the god
already got them like you're good
yeah you know what people are they're
just [ __ ] mean they're like oh i
heard about the whitaker family and
they'll try to [ __ ] with them and [ __ ]
but it's just like
it just shows that incest is wrong
on so many levels and no one is ever
arguing with that that's one law that
nobody is like oh you know what we
should get rid of that law
so yeah the reason why for people who
don't know the reason why you shouldn't
[ __ ] family members right
is because if you have a genetic
deficiency that's within your family
and that's a recessive trait and you
have two recessive traits that trait is
supposed to be very apparent with the
child that's born right so that's why
you have certain kids with
a lot of mental disabilities or whatever
or they have deformities because of
these things because you want to vary
that gene pool
that's why incest isn't really something
that anybody's [ __ ] fighting for
right you saw this a lot with like royal
families like royal families that want
to keep it within the blood
prince andrew look how look how dumb he
is he likes to [ __ ] kids you know
you go full circle for circle full
circle there you go boom roasted prince
andrew
bro got you gotcha you're involved with
the epstein's bro we all know it
how many members did the whitaker family
have how many kids i don't know
in the video we saw there was like four
people there one was like the
the lady that was sitting there that was
like the ring leader who was calling her
she's like
and she looked the most normal like she
didn't look and her eyes
were like on this side of her head like
that she was like a deer
and then [ __ ] but there was the one
lady that was like
get out here ray that was her yeah but
she didn't her eyes weren't jacked up
there was another lady next to her and
her eyes were
two different directions and then the
guy that i think his name was timmy he
was like a jokester
are they blind is that was that person i
don't think so
and then and then so they they're asking
about one of their brothers the whole
time
they're like where where's your brother
you know like were you sad when you
passed and he's like and the guy the
name ray who barks was like
and he's like communicating like the
reporter understands
yeah and he brings them to this little
grave plot
in their like front yard and it has like
a strip of caution tape
yeah and he's like he's pointing the
ground like
and the guy who's documenting it is like
is that is that where your brother's
buried he's like
right right and he's like looking at him
what the hell
he's just eating bread the whole time
just slicing like just breathing hands
yeah they take white bread and they roll
it up and they eat it
dude it's it's funny like it's super
[ __ ] up you're just eating bread why
they're just in the interview just like
hey welcome in
some wonder bread no no i wish they were
that coherent but they weren't
yeah they couldn't even say want some
wonder bread dude really it was [ __ ]
up
and then they were like timmy went to
high school that was it and then timmy
was like the jokester who would like
he's like
making him laugh he would like hide in
the corner and be like hey need his
breath
ah timmy bro and then uh thinks incest
is sick
and i can't believe he's still gonna be
your best man yeah no he's not my best
man but he's my grooming
you need new friends no i love him to
death not especially because we're not
friends anymore so that's what's gonna
happen
wait you don't believe in incest what's
this guy's deal bro hey man who are you
that's a new wave dog it is
hey let that wave roll out all the way
to the middle of the ocean all right let
it go all the way the [ __ ] out there
then
yeah i'm not trying to catch that way
that's a hard
and i guess when the argument like when
the conversation started i was in the
bathroom
and tiffany was there and a couple of
friends were over how did he how did he
how did that i have no idea because i
wasn't there i was hanging out
and tip was like she looked around
and everybody heard it and they go like
this
they all look down on their phone
they're like i ain't even touching that
topic because i'm trying to figure out
why he chose
that specific thing i don't know all the
stuff that he could have used as an
example yeah
for that cause why incest right
that's the weird part for the government
to stand here yeah he could have said
weed right yeah or guns even i mean
that's i don't understand
why the government has to stick their
nose in everything and in his mind there
was this
[ __ ] that split out it said weed it said
gun rights and then it said incest and
he went
and he was like i want to [ __ ] my sister
dead silence am i right guys and he went
haha got you [ __ ] i gotcha
yeah and and tiff was just like looking
around in disbelief like is
it's probably because he wants to be
like a jordan peterson right he probably
watches a lot of jordan peterson
and he wants to be that guy that just
breaks people down
jordan peterson is [ __ ] i've been
watching a lot of his videos not not
in sense of information but i just like
how he speaks
oh yeah he's such a great he's a [ __ ]
genius dude the way he breaks things
down
so perfectly but you're right i think
there's a lot of people that like
that like him and try to be like him but
they don't realize that that dude is
extremely [ __ ] intelligent
and well read and like understands
things on the
man reads and it turns into i want to
[ __ ] myself
they're like well why but why because
hey yep and i was like if you had a
sister and you said that
we would all kick you out of the house
have you seen this one video clip of
jordan peterson and i just saw it today
watching it gave me anxiety because
jordan peterson was sitting down and he
was having a conversation with
a uk journalist or reporter oh yeah the
gq one
is it where it's like kind of it's this
girl that she's like kind of pushing
them
is it the the the brunette or the blonde
girl
it's not she's not blonde i thought she
had like reddish hair or maybe bruno oh
so that there was that one and there's
another one where
uh it's just a journalist in the uk
or it could be australia i'm not sure
you guys can correct me if i'm wrong but
she was so annoying because
she was trying to do this whole like
gotcha type of journalism
where she was he would say something and
then she would misinterpret it and throw
it back in his face
and she did that about like 40 or 50
times cherry picking constantly right so
he would say stuff like
i'm exaggerating by the way right he
goes like well i like my phone so what
you're saying is that phone are only for
men
she would do [ __ ] like oh i know
i couldn't breathe because of how stupid
she was looking i don't think she
realized how dumb she looked yeah so he
would bring up a point about
and like i said i'm not agreeing or
disagreeing with jordan peterson i just
like hearing how he can converse with
somebody that disagrees with how he
thinks
right and i think that's yeah that's a
very difficult skill to have
yeah absolutely to be able to keep your
composure not get emotionally
uh entangled into somebody else's
emotions and still speak your point
clearly
and be able to debunk what somebody else
is saying which was what he was doing
but he would say something simple as
well i believe like women in the
workplace so what you're saying is that
women are inferior to men
and he goes that's not what i said but
that happened like 30 or 40 times
throughout the whole [ __ ] interview
it was so [ __ ] frustrating i was
surprised at how composed he is
yeah i'm like who the [ __ ] is this man
yeah right but that's who he is who he
is that
no way sorry i was just that interview
helped him blow up actually that was
like what kind of got him
oh really he was already kind of like
getting traction then that happened and
then it was
she looked so ridiculous because he was
kind of like he was playing it cool
he's playing it cool and then also in
that interview i think there's a part
where
she's telling him uh that he
he doesn't have a right to like make
other people feel uncomfortable and then
he was like look we all have the right
to say whatever we want like
this is uncomfortable you have but you
have the right to question me on my
thoughts
and then she kind of paused for a second
and he was like ah i got you you know
i gotta yeah yeah and then it was like
oh [ __ ] but like i remember that moment
it was
it was about um it was about thought
right and he was like
well in order to have thought you have
to be an uncomfortable situation right
it was like
throughout this whole interview you've
clearly said things to incite my anger
to make me upset but i'm not mad at you
for it right
i was like you're completely allowed to
have that thought and right as well as i
am
yeah and then she just got in silence
well i'm she was like
i'm trying to collect myself because
yeah i don't uh i was like
he's gotcha yeah master right that's
like master level removing your emotions
from a conversation and just like just
chest like that's like that's master
level i can't do that i'm just over here
yelling at people to eat [ __ ]
i don't know how somebody like that
could do that especially when you're
having a conversation with somebody
and they're not really hearing what
you're saying but then
they continue to say stupid [ __ ] nothing
gets you more upset
like especially with all the like the
coronavirus stuff like when i hear some
of the stuff about people saying their
arguments about it or against it against
wearing a mask
or whatever it upsets me so deeply where
i have to just remove myself
i can't look at that [ __ ] yeah it
bothers me i think part of the problem
is is that we don't promote
uh because we're all capable of it right
we're all capable of getting emotional
just being like [ __ ] you [ __ ]
like i don't give a [ __ ] what you're
saying
uh but we should promote uh
self-awareness and self-accountability
like that's that's what needs to happen
you just gotta it's hard because you
have to be the person that wants to take
the time out of your day
to have this long extensive conversation
with somebody right
and it's easier just to be like i [ __ ]
your mom
yeah and i just had the questions
imagine jordan peterson said that
at the interview he was like yeah that's
why i [ __ ] your mom and she's like
everybody was like oh jordan peterson
yeah just like you know when i talked
about the last time i
we talked about having that girl who was
uh i had a friend who was talking about
uh blackface and why she thought it was
okay totally valid yeah but then that
was that
that was like an hour conversation for
me to break down
why yeah and if you did it in an
artistic manner that's how you felt that
it should be portrayed but how people
perceive it in a community that's not
yours
it's you're you're visibly upset at them
for feeling the way that they feel about
something that was done wrong to them
yeah i was like do you understand how
odd that is whether you think it's right
or wrong whether you have an opinion
about time has passed or it's just for
the art that's your specific opinion
with your small group of friends
right when you're not looking at the
country as a whole the country as a
whole
as this group of community feels like
it's this one had it going this was like
an hour conversation yeah yeah you know
i just happened to have time that day i
got time yeah
yeah so i had time that day but if i had
to do that for every person
yeah i'd die i can't do it yeah forget
it yeah you can't
yeah that's true i can't do it i can't
do it it's just [ __ ] impossible
it takes a special person to want to do
that yeah yeah because it's easy to just
be like just every once in a while is
cool yeah just be like [ __ ] it dude this
guy's an idiot
he'll crash into a wall eventually
somewhere and that's what i usually do
like whatever i just think i'm like yeah
whatever that's your problem and i kind
of move on what if your friend wants to
[ __ ] sibling so bad dude i don't know
his brother is really handsome so i i
know that's why this is at the dinner
table he's staring at his brother
what's up hey bro hey bro what are you
doing today you've been working out
you know every time we eat you keep
looking at me stop [ __ ] looking stop
looking at my mouth while i eat bro stop
being beautiful then
let's start with let's start with that
[ __ ] yeah you know what i think
i sent him i sent him the whitaker
family documentary and he goes jesus and
not a word ever since jesus not a word
ever since so i think i think we're good
maybe he didn't really understand
yeah like the ramifications of what
having incest
incest kids yeah well i think he just
picked the wrong he tried to pick like
an extreme argument to make the point um
government shouldn't meddle in your life
which like look there's there's a lot
i feel good there's a good thing else
there's good reasons to say that
government shouldn't meddle in your
day-to-day life i get it
on paper it's like yeah why should the
government decide who i [ __ ] right
that's really what he's saying but it's
like with incest
not only is it is it [ __ ] up because
people come out and they are [ __ ] up
and they have all these issues
but also it just puts a burden on
society like we have to you know there
needs to be
shelter places medical procedures put in
place to take care of these people it's
not just
that it's it's sad one but two it's like
who's going to take care of these people
you know
that's money that's resources now you're
putting a burden on the entire society
because you can't not [ __ ] your sister
yeah like bro just go somewhere else you
know [ __ ] somebody else yeah
yeah yeah exactly and i feel like that's
not a really big problem right now
it's it's something that literally no
one nobody's got anything
everyone's fighting for it nobody's like
hey let's [ __ ] raise the incest flag
you could tell somebody that like has
never known what incest is
you could explain that to them and
they'd be like oh that's terrible
why not people do that people do that i
know yeah you just sent him the the
[ __ ] whitaker family he just writes
my bad yeah
i was tripping last night i just i was
excited to see you guys my bad
my bad i was excited to talk to you he
would have just been like i was just
trying to say some crazy [ __ ] that i
would have been like
that's funny he wouldn't be able to play
it off at that point no no no he knew he
knew he stopped your brother brother
you used to roast him for the rest of
we continue to like roast him in the
group chat and it's a lot of fun so i'm
glad he actually brought it up because
it
it creates a lot of good stories and we
could talk about it it's fun it's a good
time
we had a lot of laughs at his expense so
i love him shout out to my boy i'm not
gonna say his name
is first and last name dude shout out to
my boy patrick reilly
i was [ __ ] kevin i was [ __ ] usual
suspect ended up dude
guys so much right now man
his shirt was actually baby blue when it
started he just stuck in this nice dark
deep blue
i was kaiser so the whole time maybe i
was walking with a lip and then i was
just like
incest i love it it says baby
well everybody that wraps up this
episode
of the genius brain podcast don't [ __ ]
your siblings
that's one of the ten commandments right
i think so i mean it should be it's not
but it should be yeah
i think so because if i get 11
commandments that was 14
he dropped one of the tablets and he
broke so it was thou shall not
steal thou shall not kill thou
shall not cheat on your wife there's an
adultery one adultery
adulterize i feel like that's not the
three i know i feel like back then they
probably didn't have to say that
i don't know the it was so weird as a
christian boy i felt like i knew the ten
commandments at the like the back of my
hand well ten
ten is a lot i think like there was
there was don't kill don't steal don't
cheat on your wife sorry we gotta look
this up real quick don't covet your
neighbor's
[ __ ] don't want his [ __ ] that was one of
them oh yeah like don't
want his [ __ ] bicycle dog get
your own bicycle
uh what else i don't know oh don't use
the lord's name
every time you say jesus christ i think
we should damn it i got you
we should switch that one out for incest
first one is this i am the lord your god
you shall not have strange gods before
me duh you can't have any other gods
yeah okay that should have no false gods
you [ __ ] hurt
number two you shall not take the name
of the lord your god
in vain so when you say oh my god
but that's not is that because i was
told that's like saying his name in vain
i remember me too i heard even saying
jesus christ is a why though that's the
emotion like it's helping me through
this process
i think you're saying god's name and
strength
i would get in trouble a lot for saying
jesus christ they're like god damn it
and they'd be like
like you can't say that and i get
detention and [ __ ] because i would say
i never understood yeah that one's kind
of weird to me yeah i never my parents
say it all the time
remember to keep holy the lord's day
the sabbath right sunday don't work on
the sundays i think sabbath is a
saturday or sunday i haven't figured out
sabbath is saturday and then sunday is
the lord's day
wait what's sabbath then uh
the fourth one is honor your father and
your mother
because i'm going to hell
[Laughter]
i love my mom and my dad yeah that's not
what you said before okay cut that out
let's cut
just kidding mama done and papa done uh
let's see uh you shall not kill well
i've already okay
that fedex guy yep pathetic guy
you shall not commit adultery is number
six
number seven is thou shalt not steal you
shall not steal
number eight you shall not bear false
witness against your neighbor
what does that mean that means that when
your neighbor is [ __ ] really loud
you don't come out the next day and be
like you were [ __ ] loud yesterday and
make it awkward for them
do not bear false witness false witness
but where's the f like so or does that
mean i was like
i was about to ask this dude i was like
wait is that real because you sold me
but i saw those shifty ass eyes and i
was like never mind
it's true you shall oh number nine you
shall not covet your neighbor's wife
that means you can't want another
woman's wife [ __ ]
that's just kind of rough that's a hard
one that's uh that's it's zip time
they're walking around
kiddies i'm like i want to make titties
even the thought of it i think that's
[ __ ] dude that's [ __ ] the
thought
that i think it's more noble to have the
thought and be like damn i really want
to [ __ ] her but it's not the right thing
to do i'm not going to do it and then
you show self restraint
don't let this guy around your [ __ ]
wife cause what if you saw that what if
you shows more like
like i i how are you supposed to stop
the impulse
like you're just sitting there and then
she walks in the room and there's
literally no time
between you seeing her being like damn
she's bomb like how are you supposed to
stop the
like yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah like no
and how do you know if she's a wife or
not until you actually get to know
me and you know what you know the guy
that wrote the ten commandments someone
[ __ ] his wife that's what he
can hundred percent yeah that was a
personal one yeah because it sounds like
yeah
he goes out of place you shall not covet
my wife
your neighbor your neighbor yeah yeah
yeah yeah because the adultery i feel
like that covers that you know yeah
adultery kind of feels like that's the
home of that
umbrella you know and the last one you
shall not covet your neighbor's goods
you can't want what your neighbor has i
feel like that's that's all the nine and
ten should be all
like we make that one you know what i
mean nine and ten you combine it
apparently though you can covet your
neighbor's husband though that
he doesn't say that so ladies
you're okay or gay men yeah gay men or
you want to try something right [ __ ]
guys is cool i heard nothing about not
being gay in that
let me look yeah up are there other
commandments besides the tent
are there other extra other commandments
besides the test it says incest is bad
that's what this tiger's saying right
here yeah
he's a product of incest that tiger
check this out the bible actually
contains two complete sets of the ten
commandments
in addition leviticus 19 contains a
partial set of the ten commandments
an exodus sometimes considered a ritual
decalogue i don't know any of these well
it's a decal
where you put your pokemon cards in
that's right decolon
well i guess there's more i don't give a
[ __ ] though well guys this wraps up this
episode of the jesus brain podcast
where can they find you nick the ear on
instagram and mine is patrick.t riley on
instagram
and big mad yeah big mad shot big bad
epic
by the way i actually donated a
podcast he did a reporting machine so if
you don't [ __ ] record a podcast
i will murder you specifically we've
been recording bro we've been recording
i put in the calendar
he did do something on the calendar so
that means that's not you've been
recording you are going to you mean well
we have it we were recording last
week the week before that you sound so
nervous right now man you said i saw the
caffeine i'm
really jittery right now legit sound
like the kid that would rat out somebody
else for seeing something
and you would never make it to the top
you'll never make it to the top
that kid's a [ __ ] rat like it's a
blind little child
what did you see and then you knew what
you would like you're like i saw
everything
why you shaking so much because i saw
everything there it is yeah see y'all
next time